Mientras no haya normalidad democrática
en Perú no queremos relaciones
económicas ni comerciales con ellos así
lo dijo el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador en su conferencia de
prensa en Palacio Nacional esto Un día
después de que el pleno del Congreso
peruano lo declarara persona no grata al
cuestionarle si esto significaba una
ruptura acotó que Sencillamente todo
quedaba en pausa México es el tercer
socio comercial de Perú en Latinoamérica
después de chile y Brasil la nación
andina es la segunda receptora de
inversión extranjera directamente a
mexicana en la región empresas como
femsa ica América móvil grupo México son
compañías mexicanas con presencia en
Perú
Por otra parte López Obrador reiteró que
no va a entregar la presidencia pro
tempore de la alianza del Pacífico al
gobierno de Dina boluarte por
considerarla una Usurpadora dijo en
cambio que está dispuesto a entregar la
presidencia de este mecanismo a Chile
para lo cual enviará una carta al
presidente Gabriel boric esta
declaratoria de persona no grata ha sido
interpretada por el partido Morena en el
senado de la República como un acto de
hostilidad hacia el gobierno de un país
hermano y una falta de respeto al pueblo
de México en contraste la oposición en
voz del partido Acción Nacional ha
considerado que los dislates ideológicos
del presidente mexicano que se ha metido
hasta la cocina en asuntos que no le
competen Nos tienen en una situación
como esta